hi I'm Ryan hi I'm Sally you just seem
so polite inappropriate I'm saying I'm
Sally so we're back we're back man
that's right bet you guys missed us
pairing up together mm-hmm yeah I missed
it I missed it more Sally so today I'm
gonna watch a video of a girl who's
already broken my heart it's a video of
Hannah Hart I've seen like a couple of
her videos I think she's so cute she's
really she's adorable as ever and and I
hear she's gay I love gay people not
when I want one of them who's a woman
yeah I've noticed guys all of a sudden
want a girl when they find out she's
lesbian oh yeah man if he cuz if you can
get the lesbian that's like you're the
[ __ ] man like you just mean them so
generous a maiden yeah well it goes me
on the big day can you trust me I can't
use that as my disposal I guess I did
that though cuz everyone thought my
boyfriend was gay
the current boyfriend you're with
everyone thought he was gay yeah wow you
really know how to promote his image
well so yeah we're gonna watch a video
of Hannah Hart's
over the my drunk kitchen and a heart my
drunk kitchen thingamajig I've actually
never seen one of these she's famous for
well I guess that's why she started
being popular before I saw the one with
John Green cuz I love John Green like
he's everything I thought was everything
to you you're like most everything to me
yeah let's get this show on the road
watch another woman break my heart
more like head of breaks hearts like
this poor soul right here will make a
song about it
sell it to Taylor Swift and I want to
write you a song right now okay here we
go I'm gonna rap you a song okay right
Hannah Hart man I could pour you some
love farts I could wake up in the
morning cook you a pop-tart but you may
be a lesbian but I'm Filipino in a towel
and I got away to go yeah I don't care
that you're the part homo full homo
actually but you know what man I want to
be with you for really I wanna [ __ ]
Sally why were you dating other than the
fact that you have a boyfriend
oh look clearly you wouldn't even have a
boyfriend
I feel like if you would hug me I'd
break really so yeah why my that fact no
yours but that's why we look so
compatible and cute together let me know
in the comments below if you think that
would be compatible and cute together
what mostly compatible we would be look
at us we're gonna finally watch this
that's mary-louise Parker are they drunk
yet I can't tell I don't know I want to
make love to see some weeks
oh my mom watch that show when my
friends was on that show why she dressed
like a nurse and it looks really
interested
actually I don't really like sweets I'm
sorry I can't I can't start a new friend
should get her after that idea yeah
because she's I like brownies - it was
really human thing you analyse what
every good puns are like really good
with a oh they got the cure deli ones
that's pretty cool we should get one for
us can we not have yellow faces uh yeah
not even these real dishes they make
yeah you don't want to walk about it
yeah I'm at at times I my mom actually
has that on a shirt with like wine
did she say wax Oh her and I would be so
compatible they're not using is this a
mission I was like this she's clever
even like her Erica thought she's
yelling rhyme with fart and who's the
course is going
Taji pointing at me kiss me Sally sorry
I thought that would be the right moment
and that would have been nested for one
thing be destined for something else
entirely and that's something else
entirely it's delicious I just taste
better cos you're drunk that was
delightful
yeah yeah [ __ ] I did something kinda
similar only it wasn't under the
influence I actually made the best
brownies like weed brownies
no but you know I think I'm gonna make a
video about it one day the weed brownies
they're not lead brownies okay my
brownies are weed brownies that they
taste like as if you just smoked a bunch
of weed and then wanted to eat brownies
not like I would know that yeah I don't
know what that's like either no no I
don't have a card I don't I don't live
in LA where there's a bunch of them
around and it's so popular here no I've
never never tried it before ever the one
brownie to a few in art because I won't
brown any of it no if Anna Hart would F
me that would be so good gets me Sally
yeah can we try the rap song again more
I mean on that note what's the beat one
more time one more time get in the funk
but not too fun yeah not too funky
yeah we all work together on this you
can't just do your own beat alright
yo Hannah I just saw your video and I
don't know what I gotta do to get you to
flow along with me come on man I'm just
a little horny I see you and you may be
a lesbian but I'm one good-looking half
Italian I don't care if you're a
possibly Armenian I don't know why I'm
getting a little racism involved oh [ __ ]
I wish we had made the phone call damn
it